- It's nice to meet you, Abigail.
- It's so nice to meet you.
It's so funny because
I was remembering that
when I did Little Miss Sunshine,
I had to listen to headphones in a scene
and I was actually listening to music
because Alan Arkin,
there's a scene where
there's some language that I-
- [Kelly] Oh!
- cannot repeat on television.
And Alan was very, very,
like, not comfortable
having me listen to it.
So, he would always check to make sure
that I had the headphones on
and was actually listening to music.
So, I was listening to
the Breakaway album.
- Are you serious?
- Yeah!
- What?
- Like the whole time
that you're watching that,
I'm listening to-
- So...
- like, You Found Me.
- Oh my gosh!
That's a deep cut.
- Yeah, mm-hmm.
- Okay.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Wait, so technically I
was in Little Miss Sunshine.
That's what I feel like-
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That's what I just heard.
- We have to change
the DVD now.
- Technically,
I am a star of Little Miss Sunshine,
is all I heard.
- Yes, yes.
Exactly.
- That's amazing!
I love that they did that for you though.
He was like, I'm uncomfortable
with cursing so much
in front of the child.
- Even at the premiere,
he was like...
He would sit next to me-
- He was like talking to it.
- and would be like-
- Ah!
- to my mom and would be like,
can you get her out of the theater,
a police light,
for that scene?
- Oh my gosh!
- Yeah, yeah.
- That is sweet!
Well, we talked about musicians, you know,
that maybe inspired everybody,
but what about like actors?
Do you have any actors
that inspired you, Dave?
- Christopher Walken.
- Oh my God.
I love this guy.
- The best.
Christopher Walken.
- Yeah.
- I love Christopher Walken so much
and there was once
when we were on Saturday Night Live.
And he was hosting
and he came up before we were about to...
He was gonna introduce us, you know,
as we were gonna play.
And he comes up and he goes,
he said,
"Is the accent on Foo or Fighters?"
(everyone laughing)
And I knew how he was gonna say it.
I was like,
"Uh, the accent's on Fighters actually."
So, he got up there and he goes,
"Ladies and gentlemen,
Foo Fighters."
(everyone clapping)
- That is so funny.
- I love that.
That's amazing.
It is funny though
'cause as musicians, though,
we're all musicians, as well,
like, I am really inspired
by actors, as well,
like, just as much sometimes
as the musicians I grew up listening to.
It's just people that are creative
and really, like, I
don't know, inspire you.
I think it's a really broad,
kind of, creative field.